The Joe Rogan experience. Don't
want to hear the truth about it. Um,
we did one about a trophy hunting,
uh, animals about how cause people,
young people get so mad. I'll look
at this guy shot a lion, right?
And the truth is that, uh, in some
countries, not 100% of the time,
but in some countries they are effectively
using trophy hunting as a way to,
to protect the animals because you know,
that's how they are able to sort of like
monetize, you know, in that place and uh,
you know, get money coming in, in order
to protect the animals. And they're,
they're very specific and strategic
about it and it can be part of a good,
you know, sort of animal
management, you know,
strategy and it's being used to some
success, you know? Um, and yeah,
people don't want to hear that.
Right. It's still really hard
to me and I hunt. Yeah. Yeah.
That, that, that, that whole,
the whole lion and elephant thing,
right? Ooh, that's a weird one though.
What they can do is they can say, okay,
well we've got these elephants,
one of these elephants is an old male
that's like killing the other elephants.
Right.
And if we organize these hunts where you
got to pay half a million dollars for
the right to even go in there,
right.
Well with the old male elephants, I know
that was the issue with that giraffe.
The woman that got actually don't
know that specific case. Yeah,
there was a,
there was a woman who got in trouble
because she shot this really beautiful
giraffe.
It was really dark and unusually colored
and it was dark because it was very old.
And the older the Giraffe,
apparently the males get really dark.
It was really cool again.
Um,
but she shot it and everybody went
crazy on the internet because, you know,
she was posing and
smiling with this drought.
But apparently that giraffe had to be
killed because it had killed at least two,
maybe three young males,
and it was no longer have a
apple breeding age. So they,
they were in this situation where they
didn't have the money to take it and
bring it to a zoo somewhere and the,
they would have gotten money from
having this woman come in and shoot it.
That's what they did. Yeah. That's Sorta,
that's sort of the idea, you know. Um,
I mean, one of the issues is if
you've got an area where, you know,
one of the problems is you need to have
a reason for the people who live in the
place to care about the animals. You
know what I mean? If it's just like, hey,
the ovens are going to roam free while
you've got people there who are like,
all right, fine. So I'm
living near some elephants.
Occasionally they eat my crops
and shit and that annoys me.
I don't really give the
occasionally. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I don't give a shit about that.
And what that allows to happen is allows
poachers to come in and kill them.
Wantonly Right. But if instead,
okay, we're protecting them,
we have a revenue stream, right.
We get money when, you know,
hunters come in and pay a lot
of money to go kill one animal.
Right now we've got a way to hire guards.
We've got away.
This is now a resource that
we're protecting. Right?
And that sounds a little cynical,
but it is working in some places and it's
both cynical and effect and effective.
And we have a, we, we had
a woman on from, um, uh,
the IECN International Union
for conservation of nature,
big conservation group,
talking about how this is
effective now in some places,
if you've got a corrupt government where
there's going to pocket the bunny, yeah,
that's bad.
Right?
But the point is just because the mere
idea of someone going overseas and
killing an animal is not necessarily
the worst thing in the world.
We have to look at the
details of the situation.
And it's hard for animal lovers to hear.
Animal lovers don't like to hear that.
Uh,
yeah,
they don't. They don't. And I, like I
said, I don't like to hear it. I wish,
I wish I could be hear it either.
I wish people would just,
it just what freaks me out more than
anything is that there's no other options.
It's not like a bunch of people are
donating a bunch of money to keep these
areas clean and free of poachers.
And yes,
the amount would be massive,
right? We can, we can donate
money, but yeah. Yeah. That,
that's the w when you've got a problem
that big and intractable as how do you
save these animals, you know, and against
habitat encroachment, right? Again,
you know, people want to farm on
that land. People, you know, people,
people have lives, right?
They're not sitting around going,
the people in those countries
are not sitting around going, oh,
I love the cute elephant.
Like we have the luxury to do.
They like fucking live there.
Right? And so how do you get,
how do you get those people
in that society to, to
really protect those animals?
That's a hard question to answer.
And some places are having success with
that strategy and that's something that
we can understand. We don't have to
approve of it. And every single case.
And we can say that's really tough
for us as animal lovers. And in fact,
the character I'm talking
to you on the show says,
I still just hate the idea of an animal
being killed. Right? And I said, yeah,
so do I. Right. We try to
dramatize that emotional, you know,
resistance on the show, like that
emotional reaction that we have. Yeah.
I also don't like the idea of, of an
animal being killed brutally. You know,
I think I'm uncomfortable with the idea,
right?
But if my main goal is to preserve the
population of these animals overall and
stop them from going extinct,
maybe I need to accept that this
tough truth that once in a tie,
once in a while one's gotta be
shot through the head of the rifle.
Maybe I need to accept
that. It's, it's weird.
That's what I chose about really weird
when it comes to things that people don't
eat, like lions stuff. I don't
understand the psychology.
Michael Douglas and the,
what was that movie with the Val Kilmer,
the ghost and the darkness that the,
the lions that decided to kill those dudes
are, would never heard of this movie,
man. It's a great movie. The
ghost in the darkness. Yeah.
I feel like it's from the 90s yeah,
but it's a really good movie about a
true story about this guy that they
brought,
they brought this Michael
Douglas character was brought
in to hunt these lions
that were systematically targeting and
killing these workers that worked on this
railroad. This team of lions work
together and started eating people. Wow.
That's great. My way. And they would go,
it sounds all right. And they have to,
they have to go for the alliance. Yeah.
They have to go kill these lines. Yeah.
There it is. Ghost in the darkness.
Oh, holy hell biting tension.
That is a great hunters. Kilmer's
looking good there. Yeah.
That was pre fatso but val Kilmer free
when he went off to do it was too good
looking guy handle anymore looking
guy too handsome. That's the problem.
You had to just go off the deep end.